We're on problem 31.
A sewing club is making a
quilt consisting of 25
squares, with each side of
the square measuring 30
centimeters.
OK, and there's going
to be 25 of these.
And they're going
to be 30 by 30.
If the quilt has 5 rows and 5
columns, what is the perimeter
of the quilt?
OK, so let me draw that out.
So it has 5 rows and 5 columns
and they're all squares.
So the quilt itself is
going to be a square.
It has 4 rows, one two, three,
four, and then five.
And then one, two,
three, four.
So that's a 5 by 5.
And each of these squares,
their sides are 30
centimeters.
So how long is one side of
this quilt going to be?
It's going to be 30 times 5.
So it's going to be
150 centimeters.
Same argument, that's going
to be 150 centimeters.
And that's going to be
150 centimeters.
30 times 5.
And this is going to
be 150 centimeters.
So the perimeter is 150 plus
150 plus 150 plus 150 and
that's 600.
So that's choice C.
32.
The four sides of this figure
will be folded up and taped to
make a box.
Fair enough.
What will be the volume
of the box?
OK, so if we cut this out right
now and we folded it
along where I'm drawing these
green lines, we'll get a box.
And they want to say,
what's the volume?
Well, volume is just
the base times the
height times the depth.
So if I were to fold up this
box is going to look
something like this.
You're going to have the base,
which is this base right here.
And this is one, one, two,
three, four, five by one, two,
three, four, five.
So it's 5 by 5 base.
And then each of the sides are
going to be 2 high if I fold
this up, it's going to
be 2 high like that.
It's going to look like that
if I folded that side up.
This side, when I fold it up,
is going to look like this.
One, two, three, four, five.
That's side when I fold it is
going to look like that.
And this side when I fold it up
is going to look like that.
One, two, three, four, five.
The big picture, the width is
5, the depth is 5, and the
height is 2.
So the volume is 5 times
5 is 35 times 2.
Which is equal to 50.
And that's choice A.
Problem 33.
Where's 33, I think it's
on the next page.
OK, let me copy and paste it.
I should just copy and
paste the whole test.
OK, it says a classroom globe
has a diameter of 18 inches.
If I were to go from
the center to the
side, it's 18 inches.
Which of the following is the
approximate surface area.
Oh no, sorry, I just
drew the radius.
It has a diameter
of 18 inches.
This is 18.
Which of the following is an
approximate surface area in
square inches of the globe?
And surface area, they give us
the equation, they give it in
terms of the radius.
So if the diameter is 18,
what's the radius?
The radius is half
of the diameter.
So the radius is equal to 9.
And we just plug
that into here.
So the surface area is equal
to 4 pi times the radius
squared, times 9 squared.
That equals 4 times
81 times pi.
So it's 324 pi.
And they actually multiplied
it out.
So let's see.
Let's see, 324 pi.
And if I were to guess this, I
mean, look at all the choices.
Pi is more than 3.
So this value is going to be
more than 3 times 324.
So it's going to be around 1,000
or a little bit more
than 1,000.
And the only one that's even
close to that is D.
But if you wanted to confirm
that, you could multiply 324
times 3.14 and that is
equal to 1,017.4.
All right, next problem.
Problem 34.
I'll copy and paste 34 and
35 at the same time.
There you go.
I put this there.
All right, ready to do it.
The rectangle shown below has
a length of 20 meters and
width of 10.
So this is 10 and this is 20.
I just picked that because this
looks longer than that.
That's a 10 I drew.
I know it doesn't
look like a 10.
If the four triangles are
removed from the rectangle as
shown, what will be the area
of the remaining figure?
So what's the are before
I remove them?
It's 20 times 10.
That's the area of the
whole rectangle.
So it's 200.
And then how much area
am I removing?
So each of these triangles,
what's its area?
It's base times height
times 1/2.
That's the area of a triangle.
Because if you just did base
times height, you'd be
figuring out the area of this
little rectangle there.
So the area of this is 4 times 4
is 16 times 1/2, which is 8.
This is going to be 8, going
to be 8, going to be 8.
So we're removing four
8's from this area.
So we're removing 32.
So minus 32.
And that's 168.
So that's choice C.
Problem 35.
If RSTW is a rhombus, so rhombus
tells us that all the
sides are equal and
they're parallel.
What is the area of WXT.
So this right here.
OK, so this is something that
you may or may not have
learned about a rhombus
already.
But its diagonals actually
intersect at a
perpendicular line.
And let me see what
else we can see.
This is 60 degrees, so
this is 30 degrees.
Let's see what we can
get from this.
This is 12.
Then this is 12.
OK, I see where they're
going with this.
So if this is 90 degrees,
this is 90 degrees.
This is a rhombus, so all
the sides are the same.
If this is 60, this is 90, this
has to be 30 degrees.
And then you could actually make
a very strong argument
that these are similar
triangles.
Whatever length this is,
that's the same length,
because this is a parallelogram
and the
diagonals bisect each other.
This side is equal
to that side.
That side is equal
to this side.
So these are congruent
triangles.
So this is also going
to be 60 degrees.
This is going to be 30.
But if you have a 60, let me do
it in another color, if you
have a 60, 60, 60 triangle,
all of the angles are 60
degrees, you're dealing with
an equilateral triangle.
So that tells you that all
the sides are the same.
So if this side is 12, that side
is 12, this side right
here also has to be 12.
If that whole side is 12,
what's this length?
We already know that in a
parallelogram the diagonals
bisect each other.
So this length is 6.
And this length is 6.
Fair enough.
And let's see, if each of these
lengths are 6, can we
figure out what this
height is equal to?
Because if we know the base and
the height, we're ready to
figure out the area
of a triangle.
So let's see if we can use
the Pythagorean Theorem.
If we called this x, we could
say x squared plus 6 squared
plus 36 is equal to 12 squared,
is equal to 144.
And we you could say that x
squared is equal to, what's
144 minus 36, that's 108.
Let's see, 108.
x squared is equal to 108.
x is equal to the square
root of 108.
And I can simplify that
more because 9
goes into 108 12 times.
Let me do that.
So x is equal to the
square root of 9
times 12, that's 108.
So that's equal to the square
root of 9 times the square
root of 12.
That's equal to 3 times
the square root of 12.
Square root of 12 is the same
thing as the square root of 3
times the square root of 4.
Square root of 4 is 2.
So that's 2 times 3 is
6 square root of 3.
This is 36 times 3.
We could have said this is equal
to the square root of 36
times the square root of 3.
All right, so 6 square
roots of 3.
That's this side.
So what's the area of this
triangle right there?
It's 1/2 times this base times
6 times 6 square roots of 3.
So that's 1/2 times 6 is 3,
times, 6 square roots of 3 is
18 square roots of 3.
Now that's just this triangle.
This triangle is congruent to
this triangle, so it will have
the same area.
And you can make the same
argument that all of these
triangles are congruent.
So the area of this entire
rhombus is going
to be 4 times this.
Is that what they wanted?
Oh no, they wanted of
the area of WXD.
That's what we just
figured out.
They didn't want the area
of the whole rhombus.
They want just the area of this
triangle right there,
which we just figured out, which
is 18 square roots of 3.
I'm trying to think if there's
a simpler way of doing this.
There might be some formula for
the equation for the area
of a rhombus that I've forgotten
in my memory.
But we were able
to re-prove it.
And that's always better, to
come from basic principles.
Anyway, I'll see you
in the next video.